[Music]
I wanted to find a place for myself and
as to kind of to cast myself in it in a
book and me starring on on paper as and
play with the persona of the movie star
which you know I think people are
interested in and and fine entertaining
I always did you know and I come from my
family is there performative people and
I think every memoir is a self
mythologizing act right in this digital
time right now and this the new screen
time right the rise of this new screen
what are we losing and how can we what
can we make to connect us even further
to our own mythologies and our own
stories in our own family so when I was
writing this I saw my trajectory and my
family and my grandparents and and these
and these stories so the act of writing
was a you know an interpretation and in
a period of catching this kind of this
energy and this these stories and it's
it's performative to you know like and
that was also something that was that
was coming through with with the act of
writing was was wanting to connect with
with people and and maybe even you know
travel with it which I think could be
really fun you know a really casual
karaoke party where people really mean
this song you know they're not
performing it they're not imitating you
know and and and just play and just play
you know chill out leave your cameras
you know and there's no instance in the
audience we're all going to be on stage
now you know isn't that what this new
screen is
allowing us you know to make even more
fiction it's a it's a it's a it's an
interesting time for me it's like a
separation you know and there's a
difference between a facade and the
persona you know a facade is is evil but
a persona is something that you play
with you know a facade is something you
can't really break through and but I
think we're you know all these
archetypes are all inside of us to to
work through to listen to to be
conscious of to you know to play with
and we should be playing with it you
know we should be acting out and you
know in a safe space you know I think
but you know why is Halloween so popular
what is everyone getting out of dressing
up for Halloween you know or comic-con
you know there's a real like desire to
to break out of our skins and to be
something bigger something we're
different
[Music]